So Leute.
Ich kann nicht nur den ganzen Tag im Bett liegen.
Ich glaube, ich mache mal ein bisschen das Fenster auf.
Ein bisschen frische Luft ist immer ganz gut.
So, hä?
So ist ganz brauchbar.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie lange ich online bin.
Das sage ich euch gleich.
Und ich weiß auch nicht, was wir machen.
Muss ich jetzt erstmal so hinsetzen, dass die Nase nicht so sehr läuft.
irgendwie
irgendwie hat Twitch schon nicht gecheckt
dass der Stream on ist, kann das sein?
hä?
Moment, was zum
was macht, ah jetzt geht's
hä? okay whatever
moin Leute
Wie gesagt, keine Ahnung wie lange ich schon an bin
Aber mir ist langweilig
Und ich dachte mir wenn es mir langweilig ist
Kann ich mich auch mal hier vor den Rechner setzen und bisschen streamen
Anstatt es einfach nur im Bett zu liegen
Steiner hat eine Dankeschön für den Sub, exzellent
Du meinst die Katze? Ne die ist wieder heim
die ist wieder heim die war nicht lange da fettel stunde ist wieder heim ja weil ich
nicht gesehen habe ich kann es ja kann man zeigen guck mal hier nicht nicht eher nicht
eher bei der auch niedlich ist hier guck mal seit gestern gestern ist eine katze vor meiner
haustür aufgetaucht und dann habe ich die haustür aufgemacht einfach random vor der
haustür also gartentür ja wohnungs haustür doch haustür nicht hof vor haustür ja haustür und da
habe ich die tür aufgemacht und sagt na oder ist da rein geflitzt oder sie sie wahrscheinlich
reingeflitzt treppe hoch als ganze haus inspiziert haben schon anna du willst jetzt nicht einziehen
oder was ist hier los?
Natürlich gab es ein bisschen Wasser und ein bisschen Trockenfutter.
Habe ich ja noch da.
Und dann
ist er auch wieder heim nach einer halben Stunde oder so.
Und heute war die wieder da.
Die Chancen
sind recht groß, würde ich
sagen, dass die jetzt öfters vorbeikommt.
Heute war sie wieder da.
Das ist die gleiche.
Sieht man ja auch, wie sie abfällt.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wo die herkommt, wem die gehört.
Aber die hat ein Zuhause, weil die haut immer wieder ab.
Dann so in den Garten und irgendwie so hinten rechts rum und so.
Keine Ahnung, wohin genau.
Chat.
Warte mal kurz, die VM an.
Ne, ich mach nicht die VM an. Moment, Moment.
Wir machen ja nicht mal VM.
Wir machen ja nichts mehr in der VM. Wir machen jetzt ja Mini-PC.
Dann mach ich mal Mini-PC in Fullscreen.
Jaja, Normal Mode.
Gib ihm. Zack.
Jetzt hier.
Mini-PC einschalten. Zack.
Dann machen wir erstmal Package Updates.
Weil, ach, Linux, by the way.
Ja, ey, ich hab mich, glaube ich, gehe ich mal stark von aus, im Zug angesteckt, ne?
Der Zug, der war letzte Woche, ich glaub, Mittwoch oder wann das war, der war so brutal voll, obwohl eigentlich immer recht wenig los ist.
Und...
Und ein paar Stunden danach hat es auch schon angefangen.
Also ich denke mal, das kommt eindeutig daher.
Cache OS, by the way.
Darf man eigentlich Arch, by the way, sagen, wenn man Cache, by the way, verwendet?
Ist das okay?
Geht das klar?
Oder ist das...
Oder ist das eher nicht so geil?
By the way.
Direkt passend.
Ja, ich auch.
Das ging dann so ein paar Tage.
So ab Freitag.
Gestern ging es dann schon richtig los.
Heute auch.
Also müsste es dann ab morgen anfangen, langsam besser zu werden.
Und am Montag ist es dann wahrscheinlich so,
dass ich Dienstag wieder arbeiten kann,
aber eigentlich gerne noch ein Wochenende hätte.
Gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus.
So, hier.
Klinikkiste am Start.
Aber erstmal, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das hab ich verklickt.
Ja, so mit Tränen in den Augen
schlecht zu klicken.
Machen wir hier mal auf. Zack.
Aha, Proxmox am Start.
Exquisite.
Hab ich hier eigentlich alles
für ein Kram auf? Zack.
Und Flup.
Nee, Moment, Moment, Moment hier.
Chaterino müssen wir noch aufmachen.
Ich hatte jahrelang keinerlei Erkältung mehr.
Und jetzt hatte ich im Dezember richtig, Anfang Dezember richtig und jetzt richtig kacke.
Ansonsten jahrelang nichts, was wahrscheinlich auch durch den sehr hohen Homeoffice-Anteil begünstigt wurde.
Noch ein weiterer Vorteil.
Ich suche ja immer Vorteile für Homeoffice raus.
Aber weiterer Vorteil von Homeoffice.
Aber bei uns auf der Arbeit hustet auch irgendwie jeder Zweite.
Nee, so schlimm ist es nicht.
Ich hab kein Fieber und auch sonst nix großartig, außer Nase laufen, was halt scheiße ist,
weil dann drehen einem die Augen und man sieht nicht richtig was.
Sucked.
So, machen wir mal Update, hä?
Wie war das?
Man kann einfach Update ausführen unter CacheOS.
Warum haben die eigentlich Fish Shell?
Fish Shell ist so ein
so ein obskurer
oder wie heißt das?
Abgedrehter Choice irgendwie.
Ich habe keine Allergie.
Einfach erkältet.
Von irgendwelchen
Posten, die mich angesteckt haben im Zug.
Weil sie nicht ordentlich Abstand halten können.
Ja, wieder richtig.
Guck mal, 113 Package-Updates.
Was ich eigentlich mal gucken wollte.
Gibt es eigentlich einen neuen Netzwerktreiber?
Real Tech?
Bei der letzten gab es irgendwie letztes Jahr
im
im Juni oder so.
Da müsste es doch mal langsam neuen Treiber geben.
RTL8127.
Gibt es gar keine Treiber mehr für oder was?
Oder ist er doch?
Ach, R.
Nee, das ist immer noch der gleiche.
Nee, Moment.
Wait a minute.
Kam der gestern?
Kam da gestern ein neuer Netzwerk-Treiber raus.
Oh, das ist ja nice.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
das funzt mit dem aktuellen Treiber jetzt so gut,
dass ich eigentlich gar keinen Bock zum Upgraden habe.
Übrigens Leute, ich habe euch gebatet.
Ich wusste, dass der Treiber raus ist.
Aber man muss den nochmal ordentlich testen.
Das habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
den ordentlich mal ausprobiert aber ich habe auch keinen bock abzukriegen weil wie gesagt
der alte läuft perfekt okay ich habe solche als letzte mal hubs ich habe solche als letzte mal
gezeigt nicht 50 51 ipf minus es ist das letzte mal gezeigt hier terminal desktop ipf ipf und
jetzt passt auf. Bam!
Massive Performance.
Massive Performance. Guck.
Seht ihr, dass das schwankt?
Seht ihr, wie das schwankt?
Warum schwankt
das so? Hä?
Das schwankt immer von 9,21 auf 8,47.
Sagen wir mal so, das geht schon klar.
Das geht schon klar.
Ist eigentlich okay.
Was ich mal ausprobieren wollte ist, wo wir jetzt hier gerade auf der Kiste sind.
Wartet mal.
MonkaS.
Ich habe heute keinen Plan, Leute.
Ich bin einfach nur angekommen, weil ich nicht
im Bett liegen will, allein.